so going back to when dark girls was
first released and it screened
I understand there was a mixed reaction
because some people applauded you for
bringing this problem out into you know
general society whatever but then some
people were upset because they felt oh
well you're divulging something we want
to sweep under the rug well you know it
to things that are disturbing you know
I'm a documentarian it's one of things I
do so as a documentary filmmaker things
we put your own money up you're saying
okay I've I'm giving a voice to the
voiceless
I'm helping heal pain and that's my
attempt to help that's what I'm doing
I'm not a psychiatrist um ik to
questions that were faced we don't well
the Apollo Theater a few thousand people
want a theater and it's just like two
questions were asked one so what are you
gonna do now for us I'm saying to them I
said you know I'm a filmmaker you are so
the audience if you got something from
the film your teachers your psychiatrist
your business people what are you gonna
do is the question not me I'm not a
political leader I'm a filmmaker so what
are you gonna do and then there's okay
we got to think about horizon and then
the second thing was a lady in the
Apollo Theater I showed the film and she
stood up she was older lady and she said
Oh with all the respect I thought the
film was great but why are you Aaron our
dirty laundry that's shameful I said
ma'am with all due respect is because
it's sticking up the house
and she didn't like what I said but I
was being honest because there's so many
there's so much in the American
community but in the black community in
this nation there are so many things
that we are expecting to be solved by
someone else there's this expectation of
salvation you know somebody on this
horse or this this train of gold is
gonna come in and they're gonna save us
I remember with Waiting for Godot you
know great clay could go in there he
never came I say I've just left on rocks
waiting and I am trying to tell my
documentaries I call an edutainment
trying to say I'm gonna continue here's
information that if you apply it to the
problems that we face there's a chance
that we can have an impact in a positive
way but I cannot do that for you
that's what not what I do I am a
filmmaker and what we're finding is
somehow that's not enough
you